لقد اتهمت الحكومة الصينية
بارتكاب إبادة جماعية ضد
مجموعة أقلية الأويغور العرقية وتعذيب
معسكرات العمل والتعقيم القسري والمزيد في
حفل افتتاح يوم الجمعة مع
الرئيس الصيني شي الذي يبحث عن رياضي من الأويغور
ساعد في إضاءة المرجل الأولمبي
كيف رأيت هذه الخطوة هل توافق  مع
أولئك الذين رأوا أن
الرئيس الحادي عشر يوجه إصبعه الأوسط إلى
المجتمع الدولي ،
كما لاحظت جيك ، فقد
أوضحنا موقفنا للغاية
بشأن الوضع في الصين ، هذا ليس
عملاً كالمعتاد ،
فنحن نعلم أنه قد تم ارتكاب إبادة جماعية
هناك اتصلنا بهم بشأن
ذلك ، وقد دعاهم الرئيس بشأن
ذلك وأوضحنا أن جرائم
ضد الإنسانية تُرتكب
في الصين ، لذلك من المهم أن
يفهم الجمهور الذي شارك وشهد هذا
أن هذا لا يتطلب  بعيدًا عما
نعرف أنه يحدث على أرض الواقع ،
فقد أبلغت عنه بانتظام على
شبكتك وأبلغ آخرون عن ذلك
لدينا  هـ لضمان استمرارنا
في إثارة هذه المخاوف أه
في أه التي تحدث في الصين في
الوقت الحالي
كيف فسرت حقيقة أن أحد
الرياضيين اللذين أشعلا
الشعلة
كان من على الأقل حسب
الحكومة الصينية الأويغور
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن هذا جهد من قبل
الصينيين لإلهاءنا عن القضية الحقيقية
هنا وهي أن الأويغور
يتعرضون للتعذيب وأن الأويغور هم
ضحايا انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان من
قبل الصينيين وعلينا أن نحافظ على هذه
الجبهة والوسط.